[Applaudissements]
je présente gilles épaules quand il
était bébé pologne et des tout mignon et
recevait plaint d'avoir de ses parents
c'est un enfant pleinement épanouie un
an et demi et rigoler au moins 200 fois
par jour et ils égaient la maison et à
deux ans il a découvert quelque chose de
sensationnel le canapé c'est un brin de
pollution alors paul jeunes doivent
sauter sur le canapé il s'amusait
beaucoup mais au même moment quand sa
maman est arrivée et qu'elle a vu que
paul sautait sur canapé n était pas très
contente
paul on ne saute pas sur le canapé paul
je te dis qu'on ne sautait pas sur le
canapé cuir est tout de suite ça va
moins vous êtes son mieux pour faire en
sorte que paul respecte son canapé et ce
qu'elle savait pas encore à cette époque
là sa maman sait déjà que le cerveau
d'un enfant il sait pas gérer la
négation
c'est comme si je vous disais ne pensez
pas un éléphant rose
à quoi est ce que vous avez pensé et
puis en plus c'est difficile en fait de
demander un être humain qui en train de
s'amuser faire quelque chose qu'il adore
d'arrêter sans lui proposer quelque
chose d'autre d'excitant alors elle
continuait de plus en plus fort paul
maintenant tu arrêtes tout de suite de
sauter sur canapé je vais compter
jusqu'à 3 et 6 à 3
t'es pas descendu du canapé tuvalu ou
quoi 2-2 et demi et trois ans quand elle
est partie au coin était furieux s'est
mis à crier et la maman elle s'est
énervée encore plus à deux ans ju
c'est cette même découverte
sensationnelle du canapé savamment le
voit et elle va lui dire ceci et gilles
je vois tu adores sauter dis donc c'est
de montrer comment ça se passe à la
maison pour pouvoir sauter sa maman elle
est allée chercher un coussin et elle a
déposé par terre elle a commencé à
sauter elle-même dessus assez rusé et la
sauter avec paul et sont tous les deux
bien amusé le lendemain j'ai épaules il
s'est rappelé qu' il s'était bien amusé
en sautant mais souvenez aussi de la
réaction de sa maman et donc il s'est
dit je vais attendre que maman sortent
du salon pour aller sauter sur le canapé
donc dès que les parties il a remonté
sur son canapé été remis à sauter sa
maman en fait elle a entendu des bruits
bizarres
donc quand elle est rentrée dans le
salon elle a vu ce que paul est en train
de faire elle l'a puni il a crié et elle
s'est énervée
le lendemain
gilles aussi il avait de nouveau très
envie de sauter du coup il allait
chercher son coussin il a posé au sol
bien aller chercher sa maman ils ont
tous les deux sauté sur le coussin bédié
posé au sol et ils sont bien amusés à 5
ans nipple ni jules ne souhaitait plus
en cas d'appel paul il s'était plus sur
canapé par peur des représailles de sa
maman
il s'était plus le canapé parce qu'il
avait associé dans sa tête
joie jeu avec le fait de sauter sur le
coussin par terre à 5 ans paul et jules
ils ont tous les deux une expérience un
petit peu difficile
leurs meilleurs amis par jalousie a
commencé à se moquer d'eux devant toute
la classe épaules et jus ils ont tous
les deux eu la même réaction
sans aller voir leurs meilleurs amis il
leur a demandé
ils leur ont demandé d'arrêter elmer
amis et continuer de plus en plus du
coup paul et jules sens pouvait plus ils
ont mis un coup de poing dans la figure
du meilleur à mon meilleur ami s'est mis
à pleurer
ils allaient voir la maîtresse quand
papa de paul est venu chercher à l'école
et qu'il a appris que son fils avait mis
un coup de poing dans la tête de son ex
meilleure amie
il lui a dit ça vole ça c'est
inacceptable
tu peux faire tout ce que tu veux mais
on ne tape pas et pour être sûrs que
paul est bien compris la leçon
il l'a privé de sortie pendant une
semaine paul il était furieux
non seulement il s'était fait humilier
par son meilleur ami mais en plus à
cause de ça y est tu es puni pendant une
semaine
il cherchait qu'une chose ça savoir
comment est-ce qu'ils allaient se venger
comme papa tulle est venu chercher à
l'école la respirer
et à la maison quand ils sont rentrés il
a joué avec jules au jeu des grands
sages c'est à dire que sa maman et lui
il était en train de se disputer
ils ont demandé un petit peu a vu qu'il
avait déguisé en grand salon avec une
barbe et au de trouver des solutions
pour résoudre leur dispute
puis il a trouvé trois additions et ils
ont joué à ce jeu tous les soirs pendant
une semaine
la semaine d'après paul et jules ont
tous les deux prêté un de leurs jouets à
un copain est joué il avait très envie
de le récupérer mais le copain ils
voulaient pas leur rendre paul il était
furieux ils allaient redemander sont
joués à son copain et redemander il
voulait pas le rang du coup il est allé
chercher un jouet de copains et il l'a
cassé pour lui montrer ce que ça me fait
de plus à voir sans jouer chez lui il a
proposé à son copain de choisir entre
trois solutions
la première de lui rendre son jouet
parce qu'il en avait très envie et que
c'était la deuxième de lui échangés sont
joués contre un autre jouer mais à
condition que cet autre jouet il soit
super chouette et la troisième c'était
de lui acheter son jouet son copain il a
choisi la deuxième solution et il ya
prêté sans jouet préféré à 11 ans pâle
et jules il adorait jouer aux jeux vidéo
dans leur jeu vidéo ils pouvaient
dégommer des méchants ils pouvaient
passer du monde est monde et se sentir
super fort alors quand leur demandait de
faire leurs devoirs savait plus aucune
envie quand la maman de paul a pris
conscience de cette situation
elle a commencé par expliquer à paul à
quel point c'était important de faire
ses devoirs de pouvoir avoir un bon
diplôme
plus tard un bon métier un bon statut
social mais ça marchait pas avec paul il
avait une mission plus urgentes à
accomplir donc du coup elle a besoin de
ses biens et lui a interdit de jouer aux
jeux vidéo paul il était furieux il a
commencé à laisser traîner ses affaires
partout dans la maison exprès il a
commencé à insulter ses parents et à
bâcler ses devoirs la maman de jules
quand elle a pris conscience de la
situation
elle a passé une soirée entière à se
renseigner sur les métiers qu'on pouvait
faire autour des jeux vidéo et surtout à
comment est-ce qu'on pouvait relier ces
métiers aux matières scolaires que jules
avait besoin d'apprendre et la maman
d'huile elle a pris trois rendez vous en
rendez vous avec un organisateur de
concours de jeux vidéo un autre avec un
concepteur de jeux vidéo et un troisième
avec un éditeur d'un magazine de jeux
vidéos qu'elle allait voir un nul et il
lui a dit c'est si gilles je veux
d'abord jeu vidéo qui sait si tu veux
plus tard tu peux en faire ton métier je
connais des personnes qui en font leur
métier
est ce que ça te dirai qui t'explique
comment et gagnent leur vie grâce à ça
le jour du rendez vous la maman jean est
la pause et subtilement des questions
aux trois personnes qui avaient un
métier dans les jeux vidéo pour que
jules puisse lui même relié les métiers
qui l'inspirent avec ces matières
scolaires
les deux mamans ont dépensé plein
d'énergie dans cette thématique
deux mois plus tard paul
et est toujours puni ses parents il n'en
pouvait plus et les nombres j'ai lu et
c'était différemment re motiver pour
faire ses devoirs et il pensait de moins
en moins en fait à jouer aux jeux vidéo
quand j'ai commencé à éduquer mon fils
je ressemblais beaucoup plus aux parents
mall cop aaron hill je faisais du mieux
que je pouvais et je reproduisais
beaucoup en fait les techniques
éducatives que je voyais autour de moi
et un jour j'ai pris conscience de ce
que les punitions pouvait générer chez
un enfant
l'envié de revanche le fait de se
demander comment dissimuler ces actes
une prochaine fois le fait d'intégrer la
croyance qu'il est incapable d'être à la
hauteur des attentes de ses parents ce
jour là j'ai décidé de changer et
devenir chaque jour un peu plus comme
les parents des petits jeunes quand je
suis pas fait de 80% de stress éducatif
à 80% de plaisir éducatif j'ai choisi de
transmettre ce message
aujourd'hui j'ai accompagné plus de dix
mille par an sur cette thématique et
j'ai régulièrement des larmes de
gratitude
quand ils me racontent les belles
transformations qu'ils ont eue les
astuces qui vont trouver pour dépasser
leurs difficultés avec leurs enfants
les parents du petit jules ils sont
inspirés de leurs témoignages
le message que j'ai envie délivrer
aujourd'hui c'est que plusieurs voix
soprano
alors oui les parents jill c'est un
best-of mais c'est un best-of qui
au-delà vois ça nous demande à nous de
nous former de nous reconnecter à notre
enfant intérieur de stimuler notre
créativité
mais au dernier jour de notre vie avec
quoi est ce qu'on a envie de repartir
et si on va plus loin
quelle humanité ce qu'on a envie de
laisser derrière nous est ce que c'est
une humanité qui règle ses problèmes par
la force qui subit sa vie plutôt que de
la créer une autre voie est possible
et ça commence dans nos foyers merci
[Applaudissements]